welcome to the next session which i
think is about collaborations and I'm
going to make some general comments I
and my comments are not necessarily
directed to people interested in higher
education I've always and will continue
to be deeply interested in k-12
education too and and I think that
sometimes in our enthusiasm about our
technologies and the media that were
able to provide and many of the wondrous
software inventions we lose a sense of
the urgency of the educational dilemmas
of people not only in the United States
but around the world when I was working
for fujitsu in in of all places Ireland
it's the go to a bar called the bleeding
horse which is right next to the
organization and there's a tradition and
Irish culture that if you are part of it
you probably know people are fabulous
storytellers tradition of storytelling
and I heard this great story I never
forgot that I used to remind myself of
what the world is really like and about
every so often it's a story of one man
coming into a bar and seeing an old
friend and the old friend is drinking
and he's just so upset he's a nervous
wreck he can hardly function and his
friend says what's wrong what's wrong he
said I I just started air traffic
controllers school and six weeks into
the program and I'm just so frightened I
can't do this he said well why why he
said do you realize you look at the
screen and every blip on the screen 200
lives and
his friend said oh I can understand that
talked with him awhile and left and he
came back about six months later the
same bar and he found his friend there
and he's just perfectly relaxed and
having no problems what so what so ever
from appearances and his friend says oh
I guess you must have dropped out of air
traffic controller school you look
really relaxed you have any problems
anymore he said oh no no he said I
finished I graduated and I'm an air
traffic controller he said that but the
blips the blips every blip 200 lives he
says oh no that just blips and I always
use that story to remind myself that we
would often use counters to represent
things in our lives and ciphers and we
are in fact in a world of urgency that
is impressing itself on us at all times
not only in respect to education but
many many other things and I remember
just in continuing and in this vein if
you'll allow me to for a little while
the the first time I went to Orlando to
speak out of technology conference of
demonstrate these simulations we've been
developing in another context and
Orlando looked to me like a complete
city of light it seemed like everywhere
you went there was a kind of luminosity
I rented a car when I was there with my
friends and we started to drive and it
was actually legitimate perimeter that
if you pass that perimeter you actually
had no street lights so that Orlando was
really like two worlds there was this
one world of total luminosity and then
there is another world that lived in
darkness and if you might have guessed
that that world that lived in darkness
was actually a dark world which was
mostly inhabited by
african american people and i think that
there's a danger in the world that we
working that one of my graduate students
had just finished his PhD I think
described and defined as noto centrism
that is that we get caught up in the
luminosity of media and the luminosity
of the internet and we forget about what
he calls the pair illogical worlds that
exist that are outside of the system of
light that represents the communication
systems that we thrive and live in
communicate in and relate with them his
name is Ulysses Mejias and what what
excites me about that is it forces us
out of our own context the first meeting
I went to this morning was in the Earth
Institute and I was discussing with a
young graduate student the fact that
that she was too I asked her what a
dissertation was going to be about when
she said my dissertation is going to be
about electricity and Kenya and how to
help Kenya develop more capability and
the production of electricity guessable
can you define the problem and she said
well she said seventy percent of Kenya
is rural and only two percent of that
seventy percent have access to
electricity so that represents an entire
para logical world that is outside the
note eccentric universe of the
technologies that we represent and we
live with so that one of the one of the
things i would suggest in the form of
collaborations would be that our world
has to somehow at some point intersect
with the world that's interested in
sustainable development that's
interested in third world development at
one point the third world was actually
named as a project as opposed to a
problem and
and so there is a domain of
collaboration a second domain of
collaboration that I'd like to mention
if you go back educationally just a few
ticks you encounter and you still
encounter today on a daily basis in
schools and universities if you would
have asked what is the center piece of
the educational process it was the
textbook and if you think about what a
textbook was and still is in many many
places it was an aggregate textbooks are
aggregators of information narrative
eyes contextualization textbooks always
include in their teachers manuals
pedagogical advice for the teacher it's
chunked in a certain way that allows it
to be delivered in period tized form
okay and if you think about it the
textbook in some way is a microcosm of
the whole educational system that spins
around it as a hub so we build the
buildings to facilitate small groups of
people that get together in time periods
that are chunked so that chapters can be
covered the teachers are informed by the
questions at the end of the chapters or
directed by the teachers editions on how
to orchestrate the use of the content
that is within the textbook now what did
the digital revolution do first and
foremostly what disaggregated it
extracted from the textbook information
it criticized the fact that most
information was deeply limited not
primary in character and it began to in
a sense make the claim that the
revolution would be based on the
capacity to deliver primary source
information to young people so that they
can contend like any scholar would in a
more limited way with real information
well it's our job to remember
it's one thing to disaggregate
information from the textbook and to
present it to students but we have the
obligation to reengage and produce
collaborations with what the textbook at
one time had predetermined by a cheer
form so the kind of collaborations we
need to develop or that all people who
are aggregators of all that wonderful
new primary source content that
effectively have been has been liberated
and made president luminous we have to
now begin to have conversations with
architects we have to talk about the
nature of assessment in this new world
how do you contextualize these
activities what kind of tools for the
engagement with these digital resources
that we provide so it's almost as if we
disaggregated what was the complete
system but then we chose not to address
the six or seven or 10 or 15 dimensions
of that system that over 400 years had
been developed and really with a
foundation of what education became in
the nation state so the demand for
collaboration era seems pretty
straightforward it's it's really that we
pull together in redefining
reconceptualizing restructuring the
complete enterprise not just a piece of
the enterprise it's almost unfair to
provide information across the board and
to take no responsibility for how it's
used and to assume that somehow an
effective use of it will be
serendipitously constructed through time
by the chance causes of history that's
probably one of my strongest interest in
education is really trying to pay
attention to all of those different
dimensions and aspects of the
reconstruction of the process the
the next point I don't have to make
again you can you can if you choose to
go back to the web when the video was
available it's the first point I made at
the opening of the conference but I
think the point of departure for new
ventures that wish to be called
education will have to start with the
agencies of Education themselves and
that the battle for educational reform
has to be waged within the world of
practice it can't be done in satellite
endeavors somehow we have to produce the
collaborations that allow us to work
within the institutions of practice that
are processing people as students
through time and that's a tremendous
challenge because the process of
invention almost requires that you
separate yourself to some extent so the
demands for collaboration are almost
ones that run against the natural
tendency of people who are engaged in
the hothouse efforts to invent new
entities and and new things that are
related to different dimensions of the
work we do I I was very moved by Paul's
presentation from the BBC when he talked
about his travails at the BBC and
realized that on the one hand it's it's
very hard to imagine what to do there
but in some very real sense that
powerful institution is not going to
disappear and solutions have to be found
within it in order to allow it to become
and remain what it has always been in
the UK and they're outside of my level
of expertise that's based just on
observations that I made based on what
he said I think that crossover
activities and this is an effort to just
at least give you a symbol of activity
of ours I would call a crossover
activity and I would
okay the triangle initiative is an
effort of the Center for new media
teaching and learning to develop
immediate interventions that
simultaneously function as classroom
interventions that are built on research
that's taking place in the University
but the media objects themselves that
are realized as a result of the process
our actual community interventions so
for example in the field of social work
we have developed a multimedia version
of an intervention that was developed to
prevent the communication of AIDS
particularly in couples where one member
of the couple is already infected and we
took what was already a proven
researched intervention that works had a
high degree of reliability and through
the agency of media were able to
standardize the intervention so that we
can lower the bar for facilitators in
the field at the same time many of the
elements of the intervention that we're
media-based are being used in the school
of social work as a form of preparation
for their work in the field and this is
turned out to be an interesting
heuristic for the center now we have
about six or seven different triangle
initiatives where we have research-based
work we're developing media that's an
expression of that research and also in
advance of that research that works both
in the classroom and in the community on
I say community it's usually the
underserved populations that we're
talking about so I would say crossover
activities of this type are very
important and even on a more
circumscribed sense in the sense that
it's within the university the digital
bridges project that mark phillipson is
working on as an effort to take fields
that are usually embedded and driven by
their own jargons and don't talk to one
another and build some kind of common
language so that the world of libraries
in the world of teaching and learning
eventually will not be conceived of as
an even needing a bridge that will be
conceived of as a single enterprise with
a single language okay and lastly
you